good afternoon and thanks for joining us
for this presentation today we are going
to be presenting how Google is helping
companies to revolutionize how they
consume and deliver application in the
cloud by enabling a service centric
approach to networking we will be
presenting how credit service connect
and service directory allows to connect
seamlessly and privately to services and
manage them at scale my name is Pierre
Ettore and I'm a product manager at
Google cloud and private service connect
and with me is Matt so from an agenda
point of view first we will be looking
at the challenges of consuming services
at scale those two talking about this
service centric networking approach that
we will be leading and introducing
private service connect and service
directory and finally we'll be bringing
private service connect and service
directory together and see how they are
better together business leaders across
industries are prioritizing rose
innovation and time to market in fact in
a recent study 94% of the CIOs indicated
that at least two of the top three
business priorities depend on how well
technology team is actually so the
responsibility to deliver services
faster is increasingly being placed on
their shoulders this is a huge
responsibility that needs to be met with
the right tools and software for them to
be successful many CIOs acknowledge that
migrating to the cloud adopting new
application architecture and building
cloud native services will help them
jumpstart growth and accelerate time to
market however 80% of them report that
despite having migrated a portion of the
application they have struggle to
achieve the desired level of agility and
business benefit in conversation with
technology leaders three main points
come up again and again number one
complexity and slow speed of migration
number two they want to modernize now so
they can increase efficiency without
business
disruption and number three they want to
consume services faster and focus on
value-added services so companies are
trying to consume more and more services
faster so they can deliver on their
business priorities but we have seen
many of those companies are also
admitting that they haven't been able to
completely unlock the full potential
that this service consumption can break
one of the reason is that consuming
service is securely and at scale exposes
a lot of complexity on how we connect to
them and manage them and we're going to
look at it first in terms of connecting
to those services and then on how to
manage the application and services at
scale and connecting to services at
scale is complex today cloud and network
architects had to do a lot of
pre-planning and engineering to expose
services privately they typically had to
exchange infrastructure level
information like IP addresses and subnet
coordination with technology like VP
superior so different domain could
communicate or they had to manage
complex routing topology they also had
to do that across different organization
networks accounts making things a lot
more complicated especially if for
regulatory reasons or security best
practices the enterprise wants to keep
the services completely protected from
internet and only use IP private IP
addresses finally it is not only about
how to consume services but also how to
deliver services and we are seeing an
explosion of different type of services
some are single tenant Sunhwa with a
tenant some on demand and some are
established so connecting all services
at scale securely and privately while
enabling innovation and simplicity is
really complex the other complexity
slowing down companies to deliver on
agility and faster time-to-market
is managing services at scale as more
and more teams and companies are
consuming and delivering services we
have seen an explosion of technology
focusing on service consumption from
cloud and satvinder or new services
framework like macros
his architecture and it is all for the
best
however it came at the cost of having to
manage all those services at scale
especially in this world which is multi
everything like multi-cloud rich
environments rich environments we talked
about on train or gke
of several s function but we are also
which cluster of multi languages so the
exploring of services framework and
platform is making the discovery and
publishing of those services complex
especially because it needs to be done
in a way that is not stifling the
creation and growth of those services
team should be evolving independently
choosing the best platform of delivery
mechanism for the needs but really
living devops of cloud team with a
really complex task to enable this
exponential growth while at the same
time keeping system in control and
secure and finally as we have seen if
the cloud engineering team ends up
spending a significant amount of time
mastering complexity to managing
services at the scale increase it
becomes harder to stay as productive and
yet we are putting on their shoulder a
lot more responsibility the
responsibility to deliver on those key
services so we need to make sure that
cloud engine team can stay focused and
productive on value-added tasks so
mastering complexity versus extracting
simplicity means being able to within
the primitives that one exposes to
actually truly empower the agility and
velocity organization are working for an
extracting CP CD means rethinking the
complexity exposed from the underlying
platform and many of our technology have
evolved starting with infrastructure and
so a lot of the complexity come from
that come from those system that are
still exposing infrastructure centric
networking instead of focusing on
services delivery and so at Google we
are delivering a service centric
networking approach instead of the
infrastructure centric so Enterprise is
an end-user can focus on connecting
consuming delivering and managing
services sexually at scale services
centric networking solution focus on
services connectivity and management
without having to worry on the
complexity of the underlying
fasiq' organization can finally execute
on agility and innovation and enable
technology teams to deliver and conserve
services since the underlying
infrastructure is not exposed the
connectivity management of services
become much simpler secure and private
it accelerate the migration to cloud
since companies can connect simply from
on tram to new services in the cloud
faster
when enforcing the security standard
best practices for example leveraging
private IP space finally by simplifying
the management of services at scale it
enable engineering team to execute and
innovate faster and so with that we are
excited to present our selves is centric
networking products private service
connect to connect privately to services
and service directory to manage in the
register of services at scale as you may
have seen during the keynote from
earlier today we are excited to present
to you private service connect private
service connect allows to connect and
consume services easily and privately to
many different types of services by
focusing on service centric networking
private service connect abstract the
underlying infrastructure for both the
team consuming and delivering services
which greatly simplifies how they
connect and access services it is doing
all of that using private connectivity
meaning the traffic is never exposed to
the public Internet and finally
drastically simplified the communication
and from planning necessary to build
network architecture that used to have a
loose technology like the PCP so private
service Connect offers many advantages
and we can have we're going to look at
that in more deeper details first
private service connect in able to
consume services faster meaning on one
side consumer of services can operate
independently from producer of services
they don't need to pre agree on the
routing of subnets own IP information
and we support any type of tenancy for
the delivery of the services can be seen
alternative external services private
service connects really enable a private
and seamless connectivity for consumer
it
comes really easy for them to consume to
those services because they just need to
create an endpoint on their network it
feel it belongs to them and that's the
only C configuration they have to do
they don't need to talk more to the
person delivering that service they just
create an endpoint and now can connect
to it and as we have seen it's private
end-to-end connectivity the traffic
never has to go on internet it is all
secure
meaning the company's standards or
security standards that are so important
to move to cloud and finally it really
accelerate cloud consumption because it
enabled to support a really any type of
services could be first-party Google
services like Google services or Google
API it would be third party partners of
vendors offering the services and it
would be also the customer owned
services that they are delivering
internally making that communication
faster and the delivery better private
service Connect has been build and
designed for security scale and
performance security as we have been
talking over and over is a big big thing
when the prizes to be able to move to
cloud and especially as my consume and
we consume more and more services that
are production ready you want security
you want to feel that that traffic is
secure and with private service connect
all the traffic stays on Google backbone
and is encrypted and it is leveraging
the IP addresses of both the consumer
and the producer really feeling that
they are leveraging the private IP
spaces in scale for enterprise degrade
solution meaning we can support
thousands of private service connection
to services greatly greatly simplifying
the type of designs where scalability
and quotas or things like that we are
concerned and finally in terms of
performance private service Connect has
been build with no proxy or middleboxes
as part of the solution it is truly line
rate we're allowing the consumer and the
producer to access each other service as
if it was VM to VM traffic and so really
thinking in terms of performance here I
so we can support really as many type of
services and performance hungry services
so if we look a little bit in more
detail of private service connect you
will see how simple it is we have talked
so far about the consumer side and a
producer side and we're going to reuse
that here if you look first on the
right-hand side of the slide with a
producer a producer is offering a
service behind a load balancer that
service could be any type of services
the only thing that the producer needs
to do to enable private service connect
is to create a service attachment and a
service attachment is a new type of
resource that's really simple it just
has a name it has an IP from the
producer Network so it belongs on that
IP space and we have built a lot of
imean permission and governance to make
sure that the connectivity to that
service is going to be secure and
following the company best practices on
the consumer side on the left side the
really it becomes really simple for them
to consume a series because the only
thing that they have to do is actually
create an endpoint that will have a
target and the target will be that
service attachment and on top of that it
will have an IP address from the
consumer IP space again I highlighted
how consumer and producer don't need to
really pre communicate to pre agree on
anything the consumer use whatever is
it's its own IP space and the producer
use whatever has its own IP space and
there is no coordination needed to
connect the consumer and producer
service together so really as we have
seen for companies to fully take
advantage of the desired level of
agility that cloud consuming new
services and running cloud native
services promised we need simple and
scalable solution for connecting and
managing those services private service
connect focused on the connectivity
aspect and enable seamless and private
service consumption to Google services
third-party vendor or customer owned
services the traffic is never exposed to
the Internet and it has the same
performance characteristic that VM to VM
traffic and we can support any type of
connectivity design
really making building network topology
and accessing the service simpler so now
that we can connect to all those
services easily we need a way to manage
them at scale so now I'm gonna head off
to Matt to go through service directory
with you guys thanks Pierre my name is
Matt Deloria I am the tech lead of
service directory this is a product that
we were launched that we released to
public beta this spring and I'm really
excited to share with everyone here what
we've been doing with this product and
how it fits into google clock so with
service directory what we're seeing is
that managing services as enterprises
adopt a more service-oriented
architecture it becomes really
challenging to manage so well we're
noticing is that you know customers are
deploying services to both you know not
just on GCP but they still have some
legacy services that they keep on prem
or they even within GCPD they may be
running services across different
environments so a customer may not just
choose one particular product like you
can eat it may choose a handful of
products whether that's being Club
functions cloud run or just legacy VMs
or load balance services so it was been
really challenging for customers to
manage their entire service inventory so
we introduced service directory to help
solve this problem
so with service directory you can
publish discover and connect all of your
services regardless of their environment
or whether or not they're running on GCP
the third party cloud or on the ground
more importantly it also can scale to
thousands of services and endpoints and
can serve real-time information about
your services to any of your both your
applications and the users of your
service whether that's actually be the
teams that are deploying them or
organizations that they're being shared
with but you know like what does source
director you really enable and there's I
think three kind of core tenets of what
service directory enables for
enterprises the first is that it's a way
to discover
and published services from anyway right
and this is a really powerful thing so
no matter where your services are or
they're running or where the
applications are you can always know
that you can reach out to service
directory to define so search directory
has a couple of ways that this is this
is really leverages like the leverages
many of the features within GCP to do
this so service director he has a DNS
integration who air so if you change or
register any of your services to service
directory these services become
available over DNS within seconds we
also expose a really rich HTTP and G RPC
API that allows clients that meets any
query using you know metadata and things
like that
and be able to do that without having to
be on Google's network similarly the
search tree offers a way to catalog your
service architecture and what we mean
here is that so we have services that
are spread across many different
environments
and this has challenges that you know
nowhere does the service live what what
is what does the service live where is
like what region is it in what type of
service is it or is it a replica is it a
leader what kind of policies are
associated with the service to make
consumption of services simpler so the
source directory you have a single place
where you can then actually attach
attributes attach metadata attached
policies where you can enable all of us
and you can all do this all from you
through a through our API or you can
also do this through Google's developer
console and the other important thing
about about service directory is that
it's also a way to share services so
organizations you know generally are in
enterprise their services may have to be
shared or it may have to be restricted
so I may only want a specific team
within my organization to be able to
produce our consumer service or I may
have to share with it with a third party
which I've done into into a partnership
with the service record is really simple
you can restrict services with I am
policies and PPC service controls to be
ensured that the right people are
connected to your sources and lastly you
know is the I think one of the most
important things is that service
director he's completely managed so a
lot of ways that enterprises have
dealing with this problem today are
either by you know to deploy their own
software write their own software work
you know use static files to kind of
register their services or have an
employee open source plugins these can
be really challenging to run and these
this is actually a really critical piece
of infrastructure so what we want is the
very customers not have to worry about
running us at all so as a service
directory so you get you know a very
simple way and completely managed way of
registering your services but also
knowing that it's integrated across the
platform so you have integrations with
stackdriver you know our our G cloud and
API libraries and you know in also of
course the developer console so here's
kind of really a kind of way that neo
service directory can be used in
enterprises today so what I want to
really kind of focus on here is that
there are really kind of two aspects to
service directory right has that element
on the on the right hand side we have
you know the ways of the things to be
published a service directory so it
doesn't matter if you're looking here
that doesn't matter like what type of
service it is whether or not it's gke or
multi cluster gke whether it's a Google
cloud API whether it's on Prem all of
these services can be registered into
service directory and and a lot of these
things can be in to be very simply done
just by when you create the resource by
actually specifying the service
directory name and then from their
source directory will you know if if
does I can push things to private zone
DNS and we also use I am to verify that
both the producers and the consumers of
these services have the correct
permissions to do so now on the consumer
side you can see it it doesn't matter
you know which type of application it is
everybody can query the API so if you
know I'm running on the V PC I have a
way of using DNS to actually you look
this up for you DNS vo s RV or a records
or I can use the HTTP or to your PC API
if I'm both you know out of the newer or
on my own friend Ava let's say so we
know what are we doing with service
directory so you knows you saw a mini in
the previous slide some of the
the integrations that we that we are
doing these will be starting to rolling
out this year we're really building
integrations with with IO with when you
created an eternal load balancer they'll
be automatically registered to source
directory
same with gke services we're also going
to be adding some open source tooling to
kind of make it really simple for
developers to be able to publish into
search directory using the tooling that
they have today we're also now in doubt
saying you know partnerships with we had
one with recently with Cisco that has
just announced as part of Google Cloud
Next where Cisco's st1 offering is going
to be using service directories ability
to inform the location of services and
Cisco is using this going to inform
network topologies and policies of SD
Wang services and now for private
service connect so service directory is
playing and really you know a critical
role here and the private source connect
where your private services will be
registered to service directory and I'm
going to allow here to talk a little bit
more about why this is so important
houses very different micro tree sources
thanks man
so premise service connecting service
directory combined together really work
hand-in-hand and provide better together
story where access to service is now
easy secure and private no matter if the
traffic is coming from on Prem are in
the cloud and as companies connect more
and more services across Google services
Safari vendor and their own services
service directory really helps
engineering team to manage publishing
and discovering services allowing
technology team to deliver services
faster and more securely at scale to
really see private service connect and
service directory as kind of a
foundation for this service centric
networking solution that Google is
offering and we're excited to have you
guys straight soon and with that I would
like to thank Matt for presenting with
me today thanks Pierre thanks everyone
today for learning more about service
directory thanks for your time I hope
you learned a lot today about private
service connect and service directory we
are excited for you guys to stop this
thing
product